freunde herzlich willkommen in
dagobertshausen ich hätte nicht gedacht
dass ich das mal sagen würde steht auch
nicht gedacht dass man da wo merzhausen
sein würde heute ist aber die acht
dagobert häuser landpartie und nicht nur
ich bin hier sondern auch ganz ganz
viele andere deutlich bekannten
tropischer war die namen an
abseits davon dass das hier aussieht wie
in amerikanischen filmen gibt es hier
ein ganz bestimmtes konzept und zwar hat
jeder der großen namen der bekannten
köche die hier vor ort sind eine speise
vorbereitet die irgendwie zu den anderen
passt und auf diesem schönen gelände
hier auf diesem hof gut kann man halt
einfach sich mal komplett durch
probieren und das ist irgendwie echt
eine besondere veranstaltung sind auch
wenig leute die sind gerade mal drüber
gelaufen so in unserem alter da aber ich
sage ehrlich ich glaube es wird richtig
viel spaß machen heute deshalb freut
euch wie ich auch auf diesen tag
[Musik]
wir haben hier jetzt artischocken erst
ein risotto mit geschmorten ferkel
bettchen und einer artischocken es thoma
und es klingt schon wieder zu gut um
wahr zu sein von nächsten ist man ja nur
das beste vom besten gewöhnt werke weg
stimmt der software muss sich mal
vorstellen
ich bin hier wirklich quasi auf einem
punkt fest also street food festival
dass sie halt wirklich nur super
bekannte super gute köche und und auch
so vom konzept her was ganz anderes zu
bezahlt einmalig jan kannst überall
essen und trinken genau man 250 euro und
wir essen dieser güte zeit im
sternerestaurant 150 euro plus
weinbegleitung oder so und hier kannst
du dich wenn du nicht im auto nach köln
zurück bei muss komplett ist schon sehr
sehr will das konzept weil es halt auch
nur unglaubliche location
wie gewohnt absolut crazy plötzlich lag
schon normal lecker die sorte und normal
lecker sondern leichte säure entweder an
der issumer oder in der jury es ist auf
jeden fall ein guter start als nächstes
wollen wir zum nächsten stand der von
frank rosin und gucken ob ich
habe ihn gedreht das war kein krasser
flash zwar trotz der gut aber vielleicht
ist er gekränkt ich wollte ihm jemals
etwas böses
die wogen sind geglättet haben
gequatscht der fand das cool dass ich
meine meinung gesagt habe und der stand
hier ist nicht vom restaurant wo sehen
dass es beim die laut stern hat sondern
von green rosin war sie einer marke die
im b2b bereich für kantinen und so
weiter und so fort konnten berichtete
macht quasi tut muss wirklich sagen wenn
ich das in der kantine bekommen würde
wäre ich auf jeden fall so es ist auf
jeden fall nicht so ein standard hin
geklatscht deswegen sei nicht das curry
schmeckt richtig gut passt ein leichtes
schärfe die sachen sind fresh ist halt
eine andere sparte als die anderen
stände hier weil hält alle so auf die
super bowl küche abziehen aber das ist
gar nicht der anspruch hier sondern als
das was ist das mindeste
[Musik]
wir stehen hier formstand von hans
neuner das hier ist das gericht und
frank rosin selbst hat gerade gesagt das
sei heute das stärkste das wollen wir
uns mal ein ruhiges plätzchen um das
angemessen zu genießen
[Musik]
es geht mir wie die passionsfrucht vw
schnellste hier in der sonne aber
nichtsdestotrotz muss es probieren
gemeinsam mit king fisch und gurke das
ist der gang von hans neuner ich bin
sehr gespannt darauf also in der sonne
hier 30 grad hält auf jeden fall kein so
wie lange seine form aber es schmeckt
verstehe auf jeden fall warum mister
cuisine sagt dass er so krass sei es
schmeckt so resch duh hat einen kranz
von diesem geprüften ich würde jetzt
sagen von diesem hof mit jemand der weiß
man das alles verbindet sich in so einem
kranken sommergericht weil der fisch ist
sowie zivile einfach so wahrscheinlich
oder zumindest wir vielleicht aus der
chemie fisch plan freistaates in sesam
glaube ich dabei citrus last in
das auch so diese süße dieses sandwich
gurken manchmal haben weil es so bisher
sehr köstlich wir gehen zur nächsten
station in unserem freizeitpark für
gutes essen her ist das pure geilheit
das ungern gesehen wenn man den mit 13
was man vielleicht hier im ersten moment
gar nicht erwartet es gibt einfach brot
mit butter und salz aber wir durften ja
schon das ein oder andere mal die
sterneküche besuchen und last häufig
wirklich mit dem krassesten eindruck
hinterlassen war das brot das ganz zu
anfang gereicht wurde und ich bin mir
sicher dass es richtig gut wenn das
keine eigenen stand hat
rang 15
wir haben ja von alfons schuhbeck
geschmorte denen das schulter mit
pennetta also mit mini penner und ein
drittel häubchen es sieht schon wieder
sehr sehr wild aus und ich finde es
beeindruckend wie schnell die das hier
fertig machen so weil du kriegst es
wirklich so schnell
restaurant aber es ist halt einfach so
das krasseste essen überhaupt also ich
bin sehr gespannt probieren gemacht
wer was das für einen ort hier das ist
wirklich der himmel für all diejenigen
die so gehobene küche alfons schuhbeck
kocht er auch für manuel neuer einer der
fünf fc bayern deshalb spielen wir
ausgeruht jetzt spielst du auch besser
so wir in das wetter super soft so ein
bisschen panisch durch diese mischung
aus pistazien und pinienkerne die
palette an noch einen schönen bis diese
dunkelsten ist auch das ist frazier also
hier ist richtig so hier wird auch
jederzeit ohne kamera ihnen gehen
einfach so ziehen
[Musik]
thunfische tagliatelle und das sieht
schon sehr sehr wild aus lambrecht ist
ein bisschen schüttele es ist so ein
bisschen so oder so eine kalte speisen
kann durch den thunfisch einfach so auf
bremen
nur ein reines thunfisch gericht schon
aber die zitrus frische gras roter apfel
und seiner rede seine großmutter
abfüllung satelliten
[Musik]
von sowas hätte ich mehr es müssen weil
ich bin langsam und richtig platt und
sagt ich bin auch immer noch vollkommen
erschlagen von dieser vielfalt was es
hier alles anbietet ich glaube damit ich
hier wirklich alles probieren könnte
müsste ich zwei oder sogar drei tage
hier seien also wirklich das ist hier
wie im schlaraffenland
das ist alles wunderschön tolle anlage
überall das leckerste essen also ich
glaube für jeden foudy ist das wirklich
ein traum hier und sind froh dass ihn
erleben darf das haben wir dank an euch
an der stelle heftiger tag
aber wir sind wieder wo es angefangen
hat wir sind bei nelson es wird auf
jeden fall du bist die ganze zeit hier
am start dafür mussten müssen würde ich
mal braucht es ausgesprochen kommen weil
man schaut so ein bisschen rum und viele
sind präsent aber du legst ganze gestern
haben wir verstärkt das hat man heute
auch von anfang an da im restaurant
gefeiert aber das ist ja genau das was
so was ein bisschen worum es geht und
man ist natürlich hier auch 45 stunden
nach ja da steht schon das damalige
aber
darum dass ein gericht aber ich bin auch
zu stücken seinen kollegen probieren gut
dass man wahrscheinlich haben wir dann
was macht ein favorit von allen sachen
war es schwer zu sagen ich habe vom hans
neuner natürlich das verkehrsgericht
wenn ich aber auch schon hier überall
halt alles kassel
das gericht ist von andrea gisler ich
war ja letztens mit elf gemeinsam auf
mallorca und sein restaurant zehn
minuten fahrt entfernt wir haben es
nicht hin geschafft und jetzt kriege ich
es einfach hier mitten in deutschland
falls ihr euch fragt was das ist kein
schimmer hoch
[Musik]
zwei wissen einer für mich einer für
eric ein teller schaffe ich noch und
weil ich nach hause und das schönste
überhaupt wenn wir jetzt hier mal genau
hinschaut und zieht ist saftig hier
dieses tolle wagen fährt raus läuft
könnte der kulinarik werden
[Musik]
brieske peter kartoffelstampf senfkörner
ein ehrenwertes tender für deren wert in
absolut
aber das so sagt ich wie ist der bbi vor
dass wir letztens bei dem begann
sternerestaurant gesagt haben dass man
cheap calls benutzen kann dann ist genau
das gemeint es hat so viel geschmack ist
es so sagt ich danach food koma danach
kommen leute ehrlich ich brauche einen
kleinen moment um das alles verpackt wir
sehen uns gleich nochmal aber es war auf
jeden fall ein hammertag jetzt schon zu
mir vorbei der traum kann gar nicht so
viel dazu sagen heute vielleicht einfach
mal eben
und genau aus
[Musik]